It's like playing by braille.
You are supposed
to play by feel.
I've been with music since
I was practically born.
I can't live without
playing the violin.
It's all about the
music that's relaxed
or music that's intense that
just kills you in a good way.
In this class, I'm going
to talk about intonation,
talk about vibrato, talk
about colors, posture,
different styles of playing.
Make the bow work for you.
Don't force the bow to jump.
The bow says, I'm only
jumping if you leave me alone.
To be a musician, it's
almost like to be a magician.
You don't want the listener
to realize what you're doing.
If you get all of
that stuff you can
learn to play the
violin in two hours.
I'm just kidding.
The old-fashioned master classes
is when the student plays
and the teacher says, let
me show you how it goes.
That's not teaching.
That's basically showing.
I want, whenever they do
something, to be their own.
When I'm playing, if I don't
feel something in the music,
nothing is going to happen.
When you connect with the
music, that connection
will radiate through
the audience.
I'm going to bring some
of my students to sit in
and to have a discussion.
Is there a difference between
being intense and being
passionate?
If you can feel my
enthusiasm for music,
the class has
accomplished a lot.
To be happy,
forming great music,
and enjoy what you are
doing, what could be better?
I'm Itzhak Perlman, and
this is my MasterClass.